هذا هو خصمنا هذا هو
وقتنا وهذا ما سيكون عليه
[الموسيقى]
عندما يخرج المجتمع في الشوارع
احتجاجًا على الظلم ، يريد الناس رؤية
قادتهم يظهرون ويكونون مع
[الموسيقى] فقط
كيف يمكنني إنقاذ ابني و
ابنتي وأحبائي الآخرين وغيرهم من أفراد
مجتمعنا من
أن تكون علامة
التصنيف التالية ، وأفتخر بكوني أول مسؤول منتخب بشكل علني عن مجتمع المثليين من
مدينة نيويورك
[موسيقى]
أشعر أنني المرشح المناسب
في اللحظة المناسبة ،
هناك جيل جديد من الجمهوريين
والمحافظين قادم
سيمثل كل الناس
[موسيقى] ،
اسمي سارة ماكبرايد وأنا
فخور
بالتحول الجنسي
[موسيقى] ،
لقد قضيت حياتي في القتال من
أجل الناس  الكرامة راحة البال
ولقطة عادلة للبقاء واقفة
على قدمي والمضي قدمًا ، أعدك بالوقوف
جنبًا إلى جنب معك في هذه
المعركة لتحسين أوكلاهوما ،
ضمائرنا
هي وهي بعيدة جدًا عن المكان الذي بدأت فيه
تبدو مثل y '  كلهم جاهزون للنصر